la grande star tu veux mais tu voulais
faire comme ça
connais tu avais quelque 1 2
c'est surtout pour pouvoir s'en sortir
trouver un travail ça devient plus
difficile à cause du coc vide c'est
généralement les réponses qu'on abat à
cause du coc vide on peut prendre
personne ou en plus avec le couvre-feu
qui vient de tomber par exemple il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises surtout dans la
restauration par exemple qui ne peuvent
plus embaucher non plus parce qu'il doit
déjà mettre certains de leurs employés
en chômage partiel
c'est compliqué de s'en sortir en ce
moment c'est sûr notre but premier
l'existence même de l'équipement milram
hausse est de ramener la population qui
dans une grande situation de précarité
vers le soin parce que justement c'est
des personnes le soin la santé ça va pas
être leur priorité
eux c'est va être la survie ça va être
ce mettre à l'abri ça va être trouvé à
manger de quoi voir se protéger des
différents dangers qui peut exister à
vivre dehors
et justement la santé c'est vraiment
secondaire nous notre travail c'est
justement de les ramener vers le soin
vraiment les ramène vers le soir et c
est la relation de confiance que j'étais
habillée que ces jeunes gens qui a
permis aujourd'hui tu que je puisse
réaliser la pcr parce que sinon il
n'aurait pas été le ferment dans ses
entrepôts vidéo conventionnel